what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another song of ice and fire
video
as you all know i am reading the books
over again but this time i have decided
to make a video on each chapter
for those of you who have not read them
these videos will give you a good idea
of what is happening in the books in
this video we will be discussing lady
catlin's first chapter
this one began shortly after bran starks
ended in his chapter
we saw the deserter of the night's watch
get executed then we saw the starks find
the dire wolves in the late summer snows
this chapter begins in winterfell as
lady catelyn walks to the godswood to
speak with her husband ned stark who is
sitting under the weirwood
washing off the blood that's on his
sword ice now i know there are a lot of
fans out there who do not like lady
catlin for various reasons but i will
say this
her first chapter is loaded with a lot
of interesting information
this is when we will learn so many more
fascinating details that we associate
with al stark
it is often said that the information
given in the first book may reveal how
this story will end
what we will see in this chapter did
also happen in the game of thrones
television show but as always the book
version gives us so much more
shall we begin like i said before we
will be looking at lady catlin's first
chapter now we will get to listen to her
thoughts as well as being able to see
things unfold through her eyes the
chapter begins with her first thought
she thinks about how she does not like
the godswood in winterfell
by now catelyn has been married to ned
stark for well over a decade
she has five stark children but the way
of life for house stark can still be
unsettling for lady catelyn
almost everything in the north is very
different than the way things were for
catelyn growing up in riverrun back at
catelyn's childhood home
her godswood was a garden that sounds
like it was actually full of life
down there the colors were very bright
and alive
there were streams of running water and
massive redwoods all around
this is where birds would sing and the
air smelled like flowers
but as you all know that is not how
things are in the north
the gods of winterfell kept a different
sort of wood
the godswood of house stark is very dark
they have three acres of old forest that
has been untouched for thousands of
years
the stark's god's wood smells like
something is decomposing
there are no redwoods that grow here
this was a wood of sentinel trees that
are armored in gray green needles
of mighty oaks and of iron woods that
are as old as the realm itself
the godswood looks almost exactly as it
did eight thousand years ago when house
stark was founded
lady catelyn thinks about all of this as
she is walking into the godswood
she thinks about their gods the
weirwoods brandon the builder
and the starks of legend as well as many
other things that make hal stark so
interesting
now that we are beginning to learn about
these things in the story
i want to explain why house stark
follows the old gods
you see the blood of the first men still
flows through the veins of the starks
based on what the books say the children
of the forest were a mysterious
non-human race that originally inhabited
westeros
long before the first men ever arrived
the children of the forest did believe
that the sacred weirwoods are gods and
after you die you will become a part of
them
over 8 000 years ago is when the first
men arrived in westeros
at first the children of the forest and
the first men were able to co-exist with
one another
but that was until the first men began
cutting down their sacred weirwoods
the first men feared that the children
of the forest were watching them through
the eyes of the werewoods and they did
not like this
so they started to burn them and cut
them down that led the bloodshed that
lasted for thousands of years
eventually the children of the forest
and the first men
fought to a standstill this is when they
finally agreed to coexist with one
another
so they met on the isle of faces where
they made a pact
the first men were granted the open
lands and the children of the forest
were given the forest
afterwards is when the children of the
forest taught the worship of the old
gods to the first men
since the original members of hal stark
were first men
this is how they begun to follow the old
gods of the north
now most of the werewolves in the south
are gone except on the isle of faces
or the god's eye where the green men
still kept their silent watch
it's very different in the north here
every castle has its godswood
and every godswood had its heart tree
and every heart tree has its face
when lady catelyn reaches the godswood
in winterfell she finds her husband
sitting under the werewood washing off
the blood from his sword
something he normally does after he
takes a man's life
lady catelyn can feel the eyes of the
werewood following her
as she approaches ned the first thing
ned says
is where are the children he would
always ask her that
they're all inside the castle deciding
what to name their direwolves
as i have said before it is believed
that the names given to the direwolves
may foreshadow the fate of the stark
children
there are many different interpretations
to the names but i will let you know
what i think they mean
little rickon stark names his direwolf
shaggy dog
and what the definition of this word
basically says it's a story that will
lead nowhere
it may be funny to the author but it
could be seen as boring or meaningless
to the reader
this sounds somewhat accurate based on
what happened to rickon in the game of
thrones show
now i don't believe his journey will end
the same in the books but i also don't
think it will have a major impact on the
overall story either
brain stark ends up naming his direwolf
summer
he is the last one to give his direwolf
a name and he does this right after he
wakes up from his coma
well right before bran wakes up he is
visited by the three-eyed crow in his
dream
during that dream bloodraven shows bran
many different things
he needs bran to understand just how
important he actually is
one of the last things he shows bran is
what lies in the far
north in the lands of always winter
bloodraven takes bran
deep into the heart of winter and shows
him that winter is coming for all of us
this is when bran wakes up and he says
summer he wants to name his direwolf
summer
we know that bran will be instrumental
in the defeat of the white walkers
assuming they win in the books he will
have to assist
in ending the new long night ushering in
a new summer
hence the name he gave his direwolf arya
names her direwolf nymeria
named after a historical figure she
admires nymeria
is famously known for leading the
rhoynar to dorne
and as you all know arya's nymeria ends
up leading a pack of direwolves
arya and nymeria also have a very
similar journey throughout the story
they aren't driven from their home and
they spend many years bouncing around
from location to location
rob stark names his direwolf greywin
because he's fast like the wind
in a sense i suppose you could say the
same thing about rob
he had to become a man almost
immediately when his father was held
captive
rob had to gather the banners and take
the fight to house lannister
leading to many fast victories for house
stark
but in the end it wasn't enough
unfortunately
rob and his direwolf grey win both had
their heads removed
as you all know sansa names her direwolf
lady something
sansa always wanted to be when ned has
to execute lady
i believe a part of sansa dies as well
sansa once thought that everything was
all sunshine and rainbows
but the death of lady certainly made her
look at things a bit differently
and in order for sansa to survive she
would have to do some things that were
not so ladylike which is understandable
the last direwolf to be found was jones
who he named ghost
because he's all white and very silent
as of right now in the books
jon snow is still dead making him a
ghost in a sense
but jon's ghost may live on inside of
his direwolf ghost if
even only for a short amount of time
alright so after catelyn tells ned the
children are inside thinking of names
for their direwolves
she mentions how rickon is a little
afraid of his direwolf
remember rickon is only three years old
at the time ned
says rickon must learn to face his fears
he will not be three forever
and winter is coming the starks house
words give lady catelyn a chill
as they always did every noble house has
its words
family mottos that boast of honor and
glory or swore of faith and courage
except for how stark their words were
only winter is coming
this is something catelyn sits here and
reflects on this is what makes our
chapter so interesting
it's loaded with all these little
details about how stark
all of this history we learn about the
north will have a major impact on the
story once more information is revealed
about the white walkers
like i said in one of my last videos i
believe the books will show us
just how close of a connection the
starks have to the white walkers
in the end just look at everything that
has been shown to us so far
in the first chapter we are introduced
to the white walkers
then in the next chapter we are
introduced to brian stark
who will be instrumental in the defeat
of the white walkers
then in lady catlin's chapter we learn
all this other information about
winterfell
hal stark the old gods the werewoods the
children of the forest
ned stark sword ice and all these other
things that will directly connect to the
battle against the white walkers
and ultimately how this story will end
in my opinion
now right after caitlyn reflects on how
strange the house stark's words are
she immediately begins to think about
the stark's house sword ice
this is when we learned something very
interesting about their sword
which is something i talked about in a
recent video the sword that ned stark
has is 400 years old
but the sword's name is way older than
that the starks have been naming their
house sword ice ever since the age of
heroes
during the long night you can see how
they have all these various connections
to the white walkers
the white walkers have swords that are
actually made out of ice
whereas the starks have a sword named
ice the white walkers at least in the
show
have a night king from the lands of
always winter and the starks of legend
were known as the kings of winter when
the white walkers first invaded
it was said that a horrible winter fell
and as you all know
the name of the stark's castle is
winterfell these little connections are
endless
alright so now ned starts to talk about
the man he just executed
he says something made the man half mad
something made this man leave the
night's watch
knowing it would mean his execution ned
says he tried to talk to this man
but he was so afraid his words could not
move him then ned says his brother
benjen told him the night's watch has
less than a thousand men
not only because of desertions but also
because men are dying out beyond the
wall
we are almost immediately made aware of
their low numbers
that could be seen as the foreshadowing
for them not being able to defend the
wall against an attack
they simply do not have enough men and
westeros has made aware of this from the
very beginning
now this is a ticking time bomb ready to
explode
all the white walkers have to do is
attack the wall in full
force the night's watch will not be able
to stop them on their own
as of right now ned believes it's the
wildlings killing all of the men out
beyond the wall
this is when ned says the day may come
when i will have no choice but to call
the banners
and ride north to deal with his king
beyond the wall for good and all the
thought made catelyn
shudder in fear ned attempts to reassure
her when he says
mance raider is nothing for them to fear
but catelyn says
there are darker things out beyond the
wall when she says that
she looks at the werewolf's face and
thinks about its red eyes
watching listening thinking it's long
slow
thoughts ned stark refuses to believe
the white walkers are real
but his wife knows better than that ned
attempts to dismiss her when he says
she listens to too many of old man's
stories he says the white walkers are
gone
just like the children of the forest
they have been gone for 8 000 years
maester lewin says they never lived at
all no living man has ever seen them
but lady catelyn comes right back at him
and slam dunks in his face when she says
no living man had ever seen a direwolf
south of the wall either
until this morning this is when ned
changes the subject
checkmate lady catelyn so
then ned says why did you really come
out here
he knows she does not like their
godswood so she must have a good reason
to be there
catelyn says i am sorry my love john
aaron is dead
the news devastated him as she knew it
would
when he was only a child ned had
fostered at the eerie
and the childless john aaron had become
like a second father to him
and his fellow ward robert baratheon
this is when ned stark and robert
baratheon
acted more like brothers than friends
they grew up together at the eerie
under the guidance of lord john aaron
this is also why the death of john aaron
affected ned and robert so much they saw
him as a father
then years later ned and john aaron
became brother-in-law's
when ned married catelyn and john
married her sister liza
john aaron also did something else that
showed just how much he loved ned and
robert
you see after lyanna and rhaegar went
missing
ned's brother brandon rode to king's
landing in search of rhaegar targaryen
he was demanding to see rhaegar to
answer for his sister's abduction
but rhaegar wasn't there the mad king
had brandon stark arrested for
threatening his son's life
then sometime shortly after that their
father rickard stark
was summoned to the red key where he was
then arrested as well
he demanded a trial by combat the mad
king responded by choosing fire as his
champion
rickard was hung on the rafters with
chains over a burning fire
his son brandon was given a choice if he
could reach out to the sword laying on
the ground
he could free his father however he had
a chain tied around his neck
and the sword was out of reach brandon
stark strangulated himself to reach out
to the sword while his father rickard
was roasted alive in his armor this
sounds like something you would see in
one of those saw movies
afterwards the mad king demanded ned
stark and robert baratheon's heads
he wanted to execute them before they
could gather up forces and retaliate
but john aaron was not about to hand
them over he raised his own banners
instead
rebelling against the crown john aaron
was loyal until the very end
and i'm sure this is one of the many
reasons why robert baratheon made him
the hand of the king
now as sad as ned was he showed more
concern for his wife catelyn
and her family he wanted to make sure
liza and her son robin were all right
by now they have already left king's
landing heading for the eerie
this concerns catelyn because she
doesn't want liza to be by herself
this is also when we find out that
catelyn's uncle the black fish
was already in the veil jon arryn had
made him the knight of the gate
make sure you remember that for later
this is when ned tries to convince
catelyn to go to the vale to be with her
sister
he says liza's son needs to be around
other children
go be with her and fill her halls with
noise and shouts and laughter
but catelyn informs ned that she cannot
leave winterfell just yet
robert baratheon is already on his way
he is riding to winterfell to speak with
ned immediately
this news does make ned feel better
catelyn notices the sadness leave his
face
and you might not believe this but ned
actually smiles when he finds out robert
is on his way
this also just goes to show you how much
ned loves robert
he is very anxious to see his old friend
again he sends jory to meet them so he
can escort them the rest of the way
this makes me kind of sad when i think
about it because ned was so excited to
see robert again
but we all know what this reunion will
lead to
even catelyn wanted to express her
happiness with him but she knew
something wasn't right about all of this
she remembers what she heard about the
dead direwolf lying in the snow
she is afraid of what this means the
direwolf and the stag are the sigils of
house stark and baratheon
and they were both found dead in the
snow now a baratheon is on his way to
see a stark
lady catelyn must wonder what this means
for her family
we already know now the rest of this
chapter
basically just talks about who might be
coming with robert baratheon
this is when ned finds out that all the
lannister children are on their way as
well
we find out that ned has a major issue
with house lannister
but more specifically he does not like
tywin or jaime lannister
you see when ned and robert were
fighting to remove the mad king from the
iron throne
the lannisters waited until victory was
all but certain before they decided to
show up
ned has never forgiven them for that
lady catelyn reminds ned that he better
watch his mouth around cersei
she says the lannister woman as her
queen and her pride is said to grow with
every passing year
the dysfunctional relationship between
the starks and lannisters is set up
right away
so far each chapter has done a great job
at advancing the plot
it's becoming more and more obvious that
how stark has booked a one-way ticket
headed straight for a disaster
what i love about this catlin chapter is
how it gives us more insight into the
history of the starks
as well as revealing some bits of
information about the different
relationships
ned has with other characters in the
story in my next chapter video
we will finally meet daenerys targaryen
i would love to see you all come back
for that video
also i want to mention something before
i leave i will be uploading some
reaction videos to my patreon very soon
some of you might actually be surprised
to hear this but i have never seen the
lord of the rings movies
so what i want to do is record my
reaction to watching those movies for
the first time
and i should be able to upload my
reaction to the full movie on patreon
without having to worry about any
copyright strikes if some of you show up
and like those videos then i will keep
making them for other movies and shows
that we all like
so if you're interested in watching
something like that consider supporting
me over on patreon i would really
appreciate that
either way i want to thank you for
watching this video i am making a lot of
different videos right now so i will be
seeing you again very soon
have a great day bye
you